oh alright hey everybody
ooh that is more tilted than usual as
get bad the other way yeah that's not
too bad
that'll do hey everybody hope you're
having a better week than I am but you
know how it goes mmm ah did you hear the
news
I don't know what news oh yes yes the
Judoon are back not only that I hear
about it I realized when I stopped and
thought about it I actually have enough
thoughts on it that I'm gonna do a video
on it so like thinking about it like
I've got like more to say than I thought
I would have just talking about the
Judoon so um yeah but back you go you
have a space rhinos uh did someone ask
one of the cheers questions I I don't
care
ah product placement it's so subtle
these days got my tickets for fryer from
home
I don't get tickets in advance because I
don't need to not with my local theater
I'm actually not you I guess they do
have friends buy tickets and advance
there before
oh why but you know um I need Big Finish
monsters you want back oh I don't know
I'm not far enough into Big Finish most
of the stuff that I've heard that's like
I've only heard um Big Finish is
tailored to an audio medium and I don't
really want it visualized I mean that's
the thing about the best Big Finish
stories I'm not sure they would actually
translate that well because they're
really they're properly tailored to the
medium I didn't watch Game of Thrones
but I just wanted to say hi why me like
look despite the title of live just live
stream this is not gonna be a wall to
wall
Game of Thrones conversation I just
thought I'd put that there because I'm
you know set opening it up we can there
may be spoilers for anyone who cares
it's more it's more of a warning than
like a statement of intent for for the
day
game of TARDIS thoughts on the new
Mortal Kombat film and it'll be better
than annihilation I'll go out on a limb
and say that like III have a soft spot
for that first Mortal Kombat film I
actually legitimately think it's one of
the better video game movies that's been
made so far but it's like Mortal
Kombat's always one of those things that
I found like oddly endearing for how
seriously it tries to take itself
sometimes but it's really dumb I mean
most fighting games are really dumb so
back to the future is gonna be a musical
now yeah stage musical I heard that I
don't know I think it they just gonna
Marty McFly invent more black songs
besides trying to be good yeah I said it
honestly I'm just glad Tyrion and John
survived thing is by the time the show
ended I'm not sure I really cared all
that much about either of them so I'm
not sure I can share that sentiment
Westworld season 2 I gave up on it
really did not like it like I'm not
gonna hold that against you because like
I really liked Westworld season 2 so did
Liz because we watched it together but I
know lots of people didn't I don't fully
understand why not but I know that my
love of season 2 of West's world seems
to be a minority opinion I still don't
really understand why but I accept that
to be true Judoon has a mohawk now looks
cool though intergalactic Barbara like I
think the Mohawk I like like I would
never Rock him a lot
holy cow but like I have an odd love of
Mohawks in sup like I've actually got a
friend um who loses in Massachusetts she
hasn't epic Moss she doesn't always like
spike it up but what she does
holy crap so like respect to Mohawks I
know what you mean I still have a soft
spot for the Howard the Duck movie uh I
that's I think you're on your own that
one I just haven't seen that I need to
it so focus one of these days I'm gonna
rank all of the Marvel movies not
produced by Marvel like excepting
spider-man and x-men because those will
be their own thing so like things like
Howard the Duck in the blade movies and
daredevil and and fantastic for movies
and all of that and but there's a couple
I haven't seen yet that would qualify
for that one is the 80s Punisher with
Dolph Lundgren the others Howard the
Duck the rest of these I've seen I do
need to see those who had at some point
as of today officially lost 90 pounds
well to that I say cheers
did you see the trailer for His Dark
Materials um I saw the one that came
like immediately after Game of Thrones
ended I never read the books so like
look movie I'm not a nicer with the
thing beyond that they should have
played Killer Queen as John's theme ah
she's a Killer Queen option on Raman
John Dee's score of Game of Thrones oh
the music game of Thrones was great I I
only bought the first season's
soundtrack because I like a lot of what
happens in the later seasons is
recurrent themes and I'm as opposed to
you know completely new pieces of music
so I feel like I can just revisit that
first season's score and and like
reconnect with that and I don't need to
own all of them just joining so happy to
see you streaming well I'm happy to be
here and happy to have you on the Game
of Thrones fan Ally right before Danny
fell I thought John had stabbed himself
to make a statement to Danny about what
she was doing would only end in death
that would have been really weird I'll
show you funny things like I'm not sure
that would that would have divided fans
that much more than what they actually
did gah my hair's a mess like I wasn't
even gonna let it down because like I
need I I wanted to shower before the
livestream but like too much cried too
much crap going on so I couldn't I
wanted to leave a tie bag but I'm gonna
leave it tied back they're gonna ask me
to let down so but now I just keep
seeing like ah yeah I got a shower dear
god someone buy it 60 bucks lot and
everything I watch Howard the Duck Oh
God oh crap I think there's one open -
Shh
um let's see my cross-stitch major sous
chef yes yes it did haha yeah I mean and
like there's some other stuff I I kind
of wish I had a bigger shelf to properly
display like all the stuff that's been
sent to me in the last year it's been
really really amazing have you noticed
the similarities between Cold War and
Dalek I haven't rewatched Cold War since
it first aired but ya know kind of
similar in a lot of ways hmm about Game
of Thrones it seems without a strict
narrative from the books they just went
overboard
well like here's the general vibe that
I've gotten in terms of what went wrong
with with Game of Thrones first thing is
that they got ahead of the books now the
thing is george RR martin told them his
outlines for what he was planning so
what they did if not a one-for-one what
he was going to do they at least do the
major points that he was planning to hit
they just didn't know exactly how he was
going to get there and that is where
they fell down and that is how I think
the end why the ending feels the way it
did at least to me which was these
characters end up in a place that feels
right but getting there was a bumpy ride
they didn't know how to transition us
there without the guide of the
previously written material and it also
doesn't help that you really feel like
these guys wanted out of this gig they
were done with it whereas the story
really could have been it really would
have benefitted from at least another
year Thank You Connor star versus the
forces of evil also ended on Sunday
wasn't perfect series but still knew
knew how to invest intrigue and
ultimately impress me I have a couple of
mm friends online who really dig that
show I know I never got around to it but
I'm glad you were happy with like
anytime something you've been invested a
lot of time in if it can conclude in a
satisfying way that's that's always a
good thing
are you planning to watch the bull
no I I don't really like Garth eNOS I I
like I like the his welcome home Frank
run on Punisher but even after that his
stuff on Punisher I'm iffy on and I
honestly don't like preacher all that
much I just don't quite jell with the
guy so ya didn't know how to transition
they should have asked a trans person
but did you see Lindsey Ellis's newest
video I have not yet um I'll have to
check that out
do you play D&D not currently but yes I
have at various points
Oh God yes oh I'm sorry ah I got my
wires crossed yes Lindsay Ellis's video
on Robin Williams and Aladdin yes I did
I'm sorry for some reason my brain
reinterpreted that is Lindsey Stirling
uh who I'm also subscribed to so yes
that I have seen
I'll have another sip of water where my
head have you been watching the news
um as a rule of thumb no no I I really
haven't
watching the news depresses the
ever-loving heck out of me ah why is
there a Night Watch if the night king is
dead like people people keep bringing
that up but I'm like it it's it's a
symbolic position at this point and more
than anything I figure he's basically
being sent up there to babysit the
wildlings have you ever watched any of
each bomber guy's videos no I've
actually never seen a video of his I
know the name seems decent enough for
him what little I know water strikes
again are you going to see Aladdin no if
I have my way never see Judoon story
synopsis no no show blow the Judoon or
store me back into Doctor Who in full
force in the streets of Glouster aren't
safe
oh if anyone has anything to hide
confess now no no no don't stick the
Judoon on earth again is that the actual
synopsis mm-hmm that's gonna annoy me
now that game of thrones ended are you
interested in the spin-offs not
automatically well I want to see what
the premises of them actually are well
does your daughter want to see Aladdin I
don't know I'm not gonna tell her about
it and if I'm very lucky the weekend it
comes out she'll be with her mother so
her mother can take her to see that as
how would you rank the How to Train Your
Dragon trilogy to 1/3 all very good but
two at the top then one then three
opinions on drogon he's big like what
what kind of a picket are you supposed
to have about the dragon eye he's not
much of a character so I don't know how
to have an opinion on him yes you're
right there should be a Judoon platoon
upon the moon well played Sammy why
aren't you seeing Aladdin oh okay so
Andrew I'd I'll try to avoid the the
whole thing but long story short on
principle I have not and will not watch
the live-action Disney remakes the only
what I've seen is Maleficent because I
don't consider that to be a remake cuz
it was a drastic enough reshift and
retooling with a complete different
perspective and ultimately was telling a
different story that one I watched even
that one I didn't like particularly but
I've absolutely no interest in watching
any of the rest of these because I feel
that they are a strip-mining of a golden
legacy of Animated Classics I believe it
is cynical and that it undermines the
very nature of animation as an art form
because it reinforces the idea that the
live-action version is the real version
of the movie and that
the real question is why would the north
now an independent nation allow six
kingdoms to send their criminals to the
wall guys like sort of like the the
ending to the the ending and where
people ended up felt right to me why
would they because it's part of
negotiations and relations between
nations why do any nations allow for
anything to go back and forth because
they work it out and they negotiate and
they say okay well we're letting you do
this and that means this that part of
diplomacy it's also uninteresting that's
why you don't show how they negotiate
that stuff out cuz it's boring
would you let you would your daughter
want to see liking oh probably I'm sure
she will it's animals I should check
what weekend that comes out that one I
might get dragged to cuz that's that's
the thing I'm not gonna tell my daughter
that she can't go see a movie just cuz I
really don't want to see it I'm not that
petty but that's literally the only
circumstances under which I'm gonna end
up seeing any of these and I think the
only one I might end up on the hook for
would be Lion King cuz she really digs
animals if all the doctors had to fight
to the death who would win and who would
be the first um I mean I figure first
doctor goes down first just cuz frailty
all due respect to the guy um I mean I I
always would put my money on the attack
eyebrows coming out on top
briber look up he played eight at least
we know you're a good parent but you
have my sympathy uh-uh-uh I'll accept
that war would win maybe the thing is I
need to get to some of the war doctor
stuff cuz I honestly you don't get a
great sense of the guy off of day of the
doctor
so I actually feel like I don't know the
war doctor all that well ah seventh
doctor woodwind seventh doctor would
only win if he had the opportunity to
plan and advance which in my mind in a
battle royale situation you don't get to
do so I don't think seven takes it say
Pertwee or Eccleston damn I was about to
go to bed then I saw this stream well
sorry to keep you up but also welcome if
I could call you by an but an adjective
which would it be
deke II like what what other isin tip is
more appropriate than that regarding
your tardy your TARDIS interior video
can one ever be designed with Windows um
I guess you could problem is I think the
windows cuz I'm presumably they they
would match the exterior windows I just
think they will break up the look like
you could it's one of those things up
you could I'm not sure you should have
you ever been recognized in real life by
a subscriber um sort of what has
happened is someone who knew me in some
way who I hadn't told about this has
gone lame wait a minute alright do you
have a YouTube thing and so it wasn't
like they didn't know
I was spotted but I've had people who
like new me come across my stuff and
then like what hold on
and then like ask me about that so kind
of goodbye everyone
Oh see you some random boy uh question
what do you think of King brand honestly
is probably what Westeros needs which is
a very boring leader my guy that's
that's what that's what the nation needs
they need somebody dull brand fits that
bill pretty well got a terrible headache
today very sorry to hear that the Eighth
Doctor TARDIS and the comics had a domed
glass ceiling to look out into space it
was pretty dope oh dang that doesn't
sound nice I just hope the sequel to
Game of Thrones doesn't suffer because
of bad ending like it happened to
Caprica after the ending of Battlestar
Galactica well they haven't locked down
exactly what the spin-ups are gonna be
yeah so we don't know we have word on a
on a prequel being worked on I would be
shocked unless Maisie Williams said she
didn't want to do it I would be shocked
if at least one of the spin-offs in
development isn't Arya sailing off and
whatever she encounters that said we
don't know firmly what we're gonna get
originally there were like five
development teams working on on
spin-offs or prequels or whatever for
her Game of Thrones I think last I knew
there was three still in the running and
we don't know what all of them are so
like HBO is whittling down we may only
end up getting one or two and who knows
which ones they'll actually be
your own country could use a doll leader
most countries right now could use a
doll leader like excitement is it's not
in anybody's interest right now makes
for good TV not not the best living did
you ever see the 1960s Batman TV show
yeah a little bit um I watched the 66
movie a fair amount actually I actually
had that growing up I liked it quite a
bit uh one of the things I don't
understand that question I can't make
heads or tails of that I'll drink more
water then it'll make sense I heard
there was a water bottle spot in a
recent episode of Game of Thrones
between that and the Starbucks and he
thinks the prop department Dean yeah
didn't give but yeah yeah I saw pictures
of the water bottles and I think I've
said this elsewhere I'd like why can't
you just put the actors water in and
their coffee in a setting appropriate
prop like a wineskin or like a ram's
horn mug or you know something that
isn't gonna look out of place and you
don't have to worry about clearing off
the set is there a reason they don't do
that I maybe that's what I would have
thought you'd do what else was the war
doctor and besides the show oh yeah so
yeah there was big finish stuff I think
there's some novels as well so you the
ancillary material on the show it was
only just a of the doctor and I suppose
technically night of the doctor you'd
seem like a tiny bit but I don't count
like initial regeneration at the very
end of an episode it's like a proper
first appearance that's just like a
sneak peek of a doctor as far as I'm
concerned shouldn't the PA spot these
things well actually technically it
would be the script supervisors job
because they're in charge of visual
continuity so yeah yeah I I know terms
about about movie sets and such
have you seen the Cushing who movies if
yes opinion I have not so I don't have
one I did like they've been on the
docket for a while water soda in the set
problems maybe they don't do in case of
potential damage like I don't know like
there might be a reason but that's just
my first thought I think there's only
three sequels planned there were five
but two fell off only one of them is
getting a pilot's based on the long
night the original fight with the white
walkers code name is Blood Moon I mean
like mine's my standard thing up
basically anything in development at
this point is until I see a trailer I
don't have that much of an opinion
draconian czar Judoon I haven't seen the
story that the draconian czar in from
classic who yet so I don't know we need
we need a game of Thrones of a set in
modern era well where harmony nuclear
warheads oh dear
do you think the monster versus King
Kong and Godzilla movies will be able to
last more than a few years um here's the
thing at least to my understanding the
legendary the studio that is been
working on the on these things they this
this Godzilla movie runs out their
contract for their rights on Godzilla so
unless Toho is super happy with the
results they might not get to do any
more even if it's a massive hit because
they've got to get the contracts renewed
or extended Gunnar I'm really gonna miss
gay of Thrones
uh I like caught a tiny bit of one of
I'd be honest I kind of couldn't stand
it like I heard Liz listening to it in
another room and I'm like what on earth
are you watching she's like it's Game of
Thrones I'm like oh god so yeah that did
that was not that was not my cup of tea
glad you enjoyed it but no no no not not
not for me
Game of Thrones modern era is house of
cards well Batman its own really messed
up final season for very different
reasons granted but who dear I'd see
more animated Godzilla movies on Netflix
I haven't seen any of those yet your
favorite foreign language film okay if
we're discounting animating with the
subtitles and sticking to live-action um
[Music]
the handmaidens right up there trying to
think what else I really like The
Devil's Backbone from guillermo del toro
the orphanage is really good to try to
think if there were any others probably
are just those are the ones popping into
my head at the moment um what are your
thoughts on the John wick movies I've
enjoyed them I've been like as blown
away as some other people have but I've
enjoyed them
they're good it's maybe a bit less of a
geeky side but did you ever get into the
office knew I watched in the first half
of the first season of the US version of
The Office and not for me dips a little
bit too close into this more cringy and
more cringy end of humour which I just
don't enjoy I like I never I never
really have did you see Pan's Labyrinth
of course I did
I have nitpicks on that one though it's
on my
Dokka to do an epic rant on on Pan's
Labyrinth have you ever seen the IT
Crowd nope I've seen clips didn't love
that care for a bowl of King bran it's
iron it enriched oh dear God
favorite cereal growing up or now cuz
growing up I just have plain Cheerios
with honey drizzled on it which is a
distinctly different experience from
honey nut cheerios for the record these
days cracklin oat bran because I'm
secretly a 70 year old man who needs
fiber
have you seen rain of fire Christian
Bale movie I did how was that was kind
of a that was good schlocky
entertainment that film so glad to learn
I'm not the only one who didn't get into
the office give me red dwarf any day oh
yeah oh yeah red dwarf trounces this
stuff guys see the it chapter 2 trailer
yeah oh yeah God trailers and stuff so
the trailer for um Once Upon a Time in
Hollywood dropped so that's Quentin
Tarantino's next which I'll probably see
eventually I doubt I'll rush out to the
theater
cuz Tarantino is one of those filmmakers
who I eventually get around to seeing
all of his movies and I even think
they're good but then I never watched
them again never gotten into my hero
academia nope
I have not I'm aware of it are you a
hardcore fan of something that isn't
sci-fi or fantasy
ah ooh that's a good question I'm trying
to think of like the stuff that I've got
like full runs of or like I really dug
it because there's certainly stuff that
isn't sci-fi fantasy that I enjoy a lot
but for me to label myself a hardcore
fan means that like I've dug into it
more than just whatever the original
material is so like or you know it's
it's really occupying my thinking for a
long time so you know what something
like Ghostbusters like consider myself a
big fan of that cuz I really got into
you know I had the toys Gramp really got
into the cartoon and Doctor Who I mean
now into Big Finish and all this other
stuff but for non sci-fi fantasy mm now
really and again that's not to say that
I don't enjoy non sci-fi fantasy stuff
it's just that well a that's kind of
naturally where I gravitate towards and
like the stuff that I like that isn't
either that is like it's a single movie
you know or or it's you know it's it's
this limited-run stuff there isn't
really much that's ever held my interest
that well on a TV or whatever that
didn't have some kind of sci-fi fantasy
hook in it somewhere along the way or if
I did something went wrong with it and I
lost my my phantom do it like I was a
huge fan of Dexter till that last season
or um I was I really enjoyed house for a
while but that spun its wheels for its
last few season so I'm not sure how big
of a fan I'd I'd say it was of that by
the end see bots on Toy Story 4 why that
is all thoughts on star wars taking a
break until 2022 good that it did yes do
that
good oh yeah the Batwoman trailer I was
intrigued looks good looks solid they're
not shying away from you know from her
being a lesbian which is nice yeah
be curious to see that do you think
Amazon will do justice to the expanse
I don't know cuz I don't see the expanse
not a clue ah do you think Disney is
pushing this movie way too hard which
movie are we talking about Meg I missed
that Oh
Toy Story for like most Pixar films
don't give this many trails well I kind
of do they just most of them don't
include footage from the film very much
they like have all these weird shorts
like highlighting characters they
actually they do that semi regularly or
at least they have with the Toy Story
stuff like they've even had shorts for
Toy Story stuff that aren't even
connected to the movie so like yeah they
kind of have done that is it bad - what
- scream 5 inches from my face with a
headache yeah probably didn't care for
the Batwoman trailer oh sorry to hear
that are you glad to confirm John
Constantine's bisexuality in season 4 of
legends of tomorrow well I I haven't
been watching the legends while it aired
I've been waiting for streaming um but
yes I'm happy to hear that
can't wait for Tony's story the Toy
Story MCU crossover uh I watched two
Disney sequels from my childhood this
weekend Stallone rescuers down under a
lady in the [ __ ] - scamp's adventure
rescuers down under is good it's better
than the first one which is kind of
oddly dull is it bad that I kind of like
hell-bent despite so many problems no
that's not bad I mean the episode is bad
but you're not bad for liking it you
you see something in it that I just him
don't thoughts on Percy Jackson and
Percy J thoughts on Percy Jackson /
Heroes of Olympus series oh hi I'm not
sure you want my thoughts cuz I only
ever saw the second movie because it was
part of a double feed try to drive in
its and it wasn't good um that's kind of
all I got
thought about son persecuting Jackson oh
dear oh dear remember I had other stuff
that it was gonna mention and I cannot
for the life of me remember any of it
now I should I should go back to having
notes ready the problem is is like
normally when I take notes for me to use
I take them on my phone but I'm using my
phone to broadcast the live stream so
you know that that doesn't help
oh the they drop trailers for the black
mirror or episodes which is cool oh nice
the Netflix Dark Crystal series it got a
date that's coming out in August sweet I
am excited for that I want that I want
that to be good because I like the Dark
Crystal but I want to love it I don't
but I do like it quite a bit one else
was there I mentioned the once about
time intro and Hollywood trailer oh
there's gonna be a there's gonna be a TV
series based on True Lies on Disney Plus
which is a weird property to make a
series out of and it's being worked on
by Mick G I cannot say that guy's
quote-unquote name without thinking
somebody just by that man
owl how about Dark Phoenix
how about Dark Phoenix how badly is it
going to suck like that's that is the
question exactly how and in what fashion
His Dark Phoenix going to suck
have you started listening to deadlines
yet no I'm I'm I'm in the middle of
editing something that is taking a while
and hopefully is gonna well I'll be the
reason is taking whiles because I'm not
gonna stop until I'm happy with the
results but I hope yeah I hope it does
well there's something really
frustrating about syncing a ton of
additional editing time into something
that gets a fraction of the attention
has something that I just sit down and
rant and barely edit you know it's one
of those things where like I want to
start spending more time on this stuff
but it's it's frustrating when it
doesn't translate into much which I
which I know is the reality sometimes
that's just what happens but I don't
know it's just kind of frustrating
Downton Abbey movie oh god I keep
forgetting that's a thing that's
happening if it is a Dark Phoenix does
that mean is late in Arizona Shh I just
want New Mutants I mean I want it now
out of morbid curiosity and also I'd be
really curious to know what it was
before they retooled it because
apparently was basically done over a
year ago I think I'm realizing I'm not
liking the Third Doctor's
era as a whole so far though I enjoy I
adore John per week yeah I'm kind of in
the same place I'm not a huge fan of his
era there were bits of his era elements
of it that I love I don't like the
general vibe of it that much but he's
very good and Margit Oh God it was very
good as the master and we got Sarah Jane
at the tail end of that so you know
there's certainly good that came out of
it thoughts about on Eternals movie
until there's a trailer I don't really
have any because I have
absolutely no idea what they're gonna do
with it I don't know the Eternals but
also knowing how drastically they have
reinvented some of the other very
unknown characters like save the
guardians of the galaxy
I don't think knowing the eternal source
material means that you're gonna have a
line on how this thing is gonna be I've
been told I need my own rimshot man hmm
I'll leave that one crap
hang on did it did it to do to do to do
sorting things out
are we still buffering yes we are are we
not okay all right it's sorted out on my
end
you guys still good you still there
still with me refresh its back we're
good now better okay because I've been
so subtle about it the shirt actually my
shirt available on the tee public store
I actually put a link in the description
for the livestream it's it will be on
the teespring store as well it's just
tea public is a heck of a lot easier to
get the stuff up there uploading these
designs to teespring is a big pain in my
butt so I'm slightly stalled on that got
ship notice today can't wait for it to
get here sweet you forgot to mention the
brief oh yes the Brigadier is in the
third doctor but lest we forget he was
introduced in the second so third doctor
cannot claim to have created him to
simply continued his use which was a
good thing don't get me wrong I'm gonna
bury a boob with my hands all right
wobbly
I forgot I was wearing counseling geek
shirt I'm cool yes yes you are uh best
starting point for classic who well like
I don't recommend doing class who likes
starting a point just going forward I
recommend just find a list of some of
the best regarded stories and just watch
them in isolation like if you know the
basic premise of Doctor Who already how
he operates you know jumping around in
the TARDIS and just those places has
adventures there's like just look for
what our regard to be really good
episodes and watch those if you're
asking me for my own personal
recommendations for one's to try out for
people who have not already gotten into
classic who I think ones that are very
easy to jump into the time warrior city
of death remembrance of the Daleks those
would be some of the some of the top
ones that I'd recommend for people who
you know just haven't gotten into
classic yet but I'm not gonna say that
like from there oh and then just watch
continuously no jump around you can just
part of the fun of it you can erase all
memory and knowledge of Doctor Who so
you can experience the joy of watching
yet again would you no no I know like I
enjoy the first viewing of stuff but I I
like living with something I like having
it as a part of my life and getting to
just sit around thinking about it that
first viewing experience can be a
wonderful thing but I don't I don't
treasure it as like this sacred
experience that some people tend to do
sometimes I already miss Tyrion mm-hmm
over hated movies um the Ben Affleck
daredevil that's over hated do
like classic or modern who what do you
mean or I like both why would you put it
up or in there Green Lantern I don't
know if Green Lantern's actually over
hated like it that's one of those movies
where I'm like okay it's not that bad
but it also has almost nothing redeeming
about it so I don't know I recommend
watching spearhead from space as a first
story it works as an introduction like I
don't like spear him from space that
much I know I'm in a minority on that I
just don't like it very much Peter
Dinklage neck next doctor like I still
think the doctor should be from the UK
should be British somewhere in there
that you know from the islands but like
it'd be interesting I'll give you that I
want to say Ghostbusters reboot it's not
great but good God felt like people lost
their minds see the thing is I'm not
sure I call that over hated because at
this point in time I don't think people
hate it that much
I think people hated it for reasons
separate from the movie itself as an
actual piece of entertainment and most
of those people have found other stuff
to hate on so I feel like at this point
the people who actually remember
watching it and have their feelings
about that I feel those are pretty
genuine I don't I actually wouldn't call
it over hate it at this point
I think Castroville was a great place to
start I think Castro I was too weird to
start there to be completely honest
would it be blasphemy to have an Irish
doctor why we had a Scottish one and
maybe you could finally be ginger
Lucifer as a character that's often
referred to as the doctor what just
distracting like the thing is
that's that's actually something that'll
turn up it fairly often in others Hector
like I caught a little bit of the mask
the Jim Carrey movie from the 90s the
mask and like there's a crook in it it
was like hey you're talking to the
doctor I'm like wait what so I get a
kick out of it when that kind of thing
happens we've had three Scottish but yes
okay yes we have but I mean Capaldi were
the one who got to own it you know the
being Scottish I'd like to see a
plus-sized doctor one day honestly um
I'm down for that you won't be really
cool if they had a plus-sized doctor and
just had them you know running through
the corridors through the corridors like
the doctor always does and never make a
joke out of it never have the doctor be
out of breath never have it be weird
like I dig that Jim Carrey mask movies
one of my favorite childhood movies it I
really did enjoy the movie and I was
younger it is like most nineties
comedies parts of it some jokes have not
aged well at all but I definitely liked
it when I was young
Phantom Menace is over hated I yeah
maybe
I think Phantom Menace maybe gets
slightly more hate than it deserves
because it's hated more for what it
represents in addition to the fact that
it's not a very good movie because let's
be honest it isn't I never got into Star
Wars please don't hurt me
that's okay you're allowed to not have
gotten into something I just want Missy
back oh yeah I'm I am missing Michelle
Gomez these days she was really great in
that role
I tried to I just came falling asleep
during the old one well they try one of
the newer ones I mean unless unless you
really decide it's not for you which
again is fine you're allowed to do that
it's okay I think Revenge of the Sith
gets a free pass too much I don't think
it's a free pass but it is the best of
the prequels I think I think it's hard
to argue otherwise
Missy is awesome on Big Finish yeah I do
need to get some of that stuff I just
realized that Doctor Who stuff look like
a dr. Seuss book
Doctor Who of who-ville shouldn't the
doctor's companion ever be a stowaway
I feel like they'd um at somewhere like
in one of the one of the ancillary
things like maybe in the comics or
something I don't know I mean part of it
is just the nature of the TARDIS you're
not supposed to be able to get stowaways
that's not to say that you couldn't find
a way to do it but any kind of he kind
of has like he's had people end up on
the TARDIS
you know unintentionally before so I did
didn't um didn't Sarah Jane initially
stow away on the TARDIS in time warrior
trying to remember now trying to
remember how she got back in time I
think she did actually yeah I think so
Adric was the stowaway oh yeah see I
haven't seen a droids um premiere
episode yet so
but people hate the new ones I don't
know out of it okay well look here's the
thing
the people who don't like the new Star
Wars it has to do with how it conflicts
with how they feel about the older Star
Wars so if you didn't like the older
Star Wars then you I would actually
think you'd might even have a better
shot at liking the newer Star Wars then
because of the people and like I include
myself with this the people who really
didn't like say for instance the last
Jedi a lot of that has to do with our
own hang-ups and baggage and you know
love of the originals so if you don't
have that then that shouldn't be bogging
you down and Star Wars Disney rogue one
the force awakens last Jedi solo which
doctors TARDIS would you stowaway on
well yeah I mean problem is you don't
know which Kurtis you've got until you
get inside that's the trick
so my luck I'd end up with the the
boring flat wall one that the Fourth
Doctor had for a while I do not like the
new trilogy at all yeah some some folks
don't do not like old Star Wars quite
like the last night oh god did we just
kick off a whole Star Wars thing ah
don't don't attack each other my best
friend lost interests and Star Wars
since Han died that's actually that's
where my mother is my mother was like a
rig like Oh like original Star Wars fan
but yeah once once they killed Han she
she kind of was like oh is that what
they're doing yeah she and she kind of
zoned out after that I liked the last
Jedi please don't kill me it's okay
you're allowed to like whatever you like
I don't but it's not a crime to like the
last Jedi it's not a crying - like help
vent
okay might be you crime - like the last
episode of Dexter but it's a misdemeanor
at worst the Ewok movies
obviously the best one oh now those are
fighting words Oh your mom too okay Star
Wars love love the way they star those
Wars yep those Wars sure did star in
their Wars ah excuse me folks
I got a ban somebody just give me a
second I love that this person thinks
they're winding me up and all they're
doing is requiring about about thirty
seconds of my time to go a goodbye
mm-hmm that was easy
favorite scene from the tenon era ooh I
don't know if I could nail down um
single scene I mean the heartbreaking
scene from the tenant eras when he has
to wipe Donna's memory I don't know if
that's a favorite though
it's impactful as heck though more
planet [ __ ] than stars well yeah I
don't know if quoting this is gonna get
me demonetized but Yahtzee Cronshaw in a
review of a Star Wars game said you know
this shouldn't really be called Star
Wars it's not the stars that are having
the wars is a bunch of [ __ ] they should
call it [ __ ] Wars best impression of
David Spade buh-bye troll bye bye Bob
bye bye bye bye
I'm on tumblr and God the discourse is a
mess I
what is tumblr like now that the porn is
gone
I I just find myself wondering sometimes
not enough to like go and investigate
but did like what what's it like now
because I feel like it before
you were you were always like you
instead of six degrees of seven bacon
you were six degrees of porn and I like
no matter what you click on a string of
things within six clicks you're looking
at porn and so if that's not there like
what's it like now I don't even know
gotta love the window teen from adipose
I actually don't it's a little too much
for me it's a little overdone read it
for the win I mean I like read it but
like you got to be careful which
subreddits you wander onto um but as a
platform I like it well enough like what
I saw Star tube before Amazon stole it
from Lulu and net and Netflix I just
wish there wasn't romance in companions
on the doctor just feels weird yeah
another the doctor companion romance
thing that's a modern era thing and hi
II don't much care for it ever really
have different doctors tortoises are
very easy to tell apart I will post a
comparison link but yes okay yes some of
them cuz like some of them have the the
ambulance the st. Johns Ambulance thing
on him some don't but like I couldn't
identify most doctors from the exterior
TARDIS on sight I know some people could
I can't the four is still kind of there
to be honest they find a way I mean like
I'm not surprised by that but it's
really just discourse and reblogging the
same means and 50 different variations I
like it
cool I mean good good if you're if
you're on tumblr
I would hope it's because you like it
it's it's when you is when you hang out
somewhere and you're like oh why do I
even do this that's just like we'll take
a step away life and porn find a way yes
they do
I've liked Oh ever watch a vicious oh
okay whoo I got nervous there for a
second cuz some was like I like vicious
and like I've been I've been working on
on Cowboy Bebop related stuff and for a
second I thought someone said they liked
vicious like the character from Cowboy
Bebop
and I was like wait what but okay so it
wasn't that no I haven't seen that the
TV show vicious with Derek Jacobi and
Ian McKellen um I've seen clips I
haven't seen an actual episode as yet
though there's some weird creatures on
tumblr it's the Internet there's weird
creatures everywhere demonetised yeah
yeah we I've mentioned porn multiple
times BDSM and Daleks yeah like at this
point I might as well own it that that
this this the archived version of this
livestream is gonna be didn't deep
monetize now ah cowboy bebop what a
fantastic anime I will have hopefully
finish editing it a video on that the
end of next week I was just buying some
items from a certain counsel from
certain geek council really which one no
seriously if it's anyone besides me I
like I need to hunt them down and say
they're treading on my turf best Batman
I'm Kevin Conroy live-action Michael
Keaton vicious is - haha gay for me and
the clips I saw were cute enough I do
wonder if it were great on me for
the entirety of an episode much less the
series but like I got a chuckle out of
it the day I did good chemistry together
you should try JoJo's Bizarre Adventure
like people have told me all kinds of
anime that I should try and the vast
majority of them I watch a little bit
I'm like and know like I'm trying to
think the animes that I started and
never came back to and again none of
these are there because I think they're
bad they just didn't grab me enough for
me to keep going so attack on Titan
[Music]
Trigon one punch man Death Note there
are others like of the anime shows that
I've seen the only ones I've seen all
the way through the original um Full
Metal Alchemist
I've seen all the way through I did like
I did one episode of full Alchemist
Brotherhood I'm like no like again I'm
like this is not different enough from
what I already saw and I didn't want to
re-watch it again but I saw that one all
the way through I saw the first hell the
first version of Helsing all the way
through even though it completely fell
apart by the end I've seen Cowboy Bebop
all the way through and I've seen
escaflowne which to date is my favorite
um as far as that my series is go if you
start JoJo's don't start with part 1 or
2 it gets more interesting once that oh
that's always the thing some of these
cabinets oh well you can't start at the
beginning you got to start here it's
like that's usually a hint that
something's a little off and that's not
to say let that like a show isn't
allowed to get better over time but you
realize that that's a hurdle for for new
people coming in Game of Thrones best
season for oh the charm on my necklace
this
that is an acorn and an oak leaf what's
actually what's cool about the necklace
is these are actually two separate
things it's not it's not like one piece
welded together so I actually really
like that about that technically not
anime but inspired by it we watch Avatar
The Last Airbender I mean like
eventually I would oh that's the other
one I've seen us Afro Samurai I've seen
all the way through a bunch of glass
there but I like it's been on my to-do
list for ages like eventually probably I
don't know when the hell boy Roo you
booth thoughts haven't seen it so no I
don't have any one piece I haven't seen
any of Afro Samurai is crazy yes it is
yes in the best possible way just so you
know after the first 13 episodes it
varies vastly from the original anime
Full Metal Alchemist Brotherhood I mean
it wasn't just that it was telling the
same story it's that it immediately
reminded me of all the things about full
metal alchemist that bugged me and I'm
like even if this story goes in a new
direction
I'm I was done I didn't need more full
metal alchemist prone warps oh dear I
think I missed something there Steve
ankle just reviewed two good and broody
yeah it's funny I saw his review I
didn't even know - Gunn birdy was a
thing but I watched his review because I
love Stu's stuff
it's fantastic neon genesis evangelion
never seen it I'm well aware of it but
I've never seen it
did you arch space dandy nope no I have
not like I haven't seen a lot of this a
lot a lot of the anime series like I
mentioned this before I I buy a large I
tend to
joy anime film more than my shows I feel
like the shows indulge a little bit more
in the sort of tropes and elements of
anime that I don't like as much and I
don't see that turn up in the movies as
frequently my flirting cat needs feeding
take care look for the adventure when
Aria saves the TARDIS and doctor at sea
the doctor calls Aria a shield er like
as much as you know there's a certain
taint because she was involved in Hell
Ben I would be totally cool with her
coming back with that character coming
back again but unfortunately since she
went off and traveled with Cara I guess
we can't really have her back without
post although you could do a little
River Song thing and have the doctor
meet her again just not at that point in
her timeline could be earlier again
could be between the woman who lived and
hell-bent so could still happen I'd be
down for that not to sound like a broken
record but I swear I'm not paid by
Amazon but the expands should be
required viewing for sci-fi fans I'm
sure it's good I've heard enough people
say that it is but I just I haven't I
haven't gotten to it altered carbon oh
yes I have started watching altered
carbon I've only just started I've been
commissioned for that one so I've got
started on that and I'm still working on
a book and and I've got the review for
the first two episodes of the oh eh
that'll be out on Friday like I'm trying
to catch up on Commission's because I've
had a few pile-up on me lately do you
think wolf and Graham would be great
friends yes
try to think like is there in somewhere
which they might annoying each other no
I think I think they actually would I
want to watch altered carbon but it's a
show I can't like passively watch so
it's taken me a while I mean it's it's a
if nothing else is a very visually dense
show so you do have to kind of pay
attention to it what season three of the
oh I know no first two episodes of the
first season was what I was commissioned
to take a look at have you gotten the
chance to listen to the Hamilton
Hamilton soundtrack no I haven't but you
know what I did listen to others into
the series 11 soundtrack and I was
surprised how much that I liked it
given that the music left so little
impression on me when the series was
actually airing and I think I'm actually
gonna dedicate a video into talking
about that soundtrack because it's a lot
better than I was left thinking just
because it's it it's more ambient and it
doesn't draw as much attention to itself
as marigolds did which doesn't make it
better or worse it just makes it at
times less noticeable
I don't remember music in series 11
that's kind of my point I didn't really
either but then I actually listened to
the soundtrack in isolation I'm like
actually really like this huh weird I
think most Wilf and grace ah Bernard
Cribbins Anne is a national treasure and
a huge part of Doctor Who history I love
ya know he's he's just wonderful I did
not know there was a legion season Tree
season Tree season 3 trailer yet okay I
need to stop I need to wrap this up I
need to go take a shower I need to
finish my water
in my official blog available through
the teespring while I wear my shirt
available through the T public store I'm
sending into two different places
because I don't know how to properly
organize and merchandise myself hi
welcome to my channel I only kind of
know what I'm doing
bhai we love you ah thank you
I get that shirt for Portland bride do
me I mean that I I was very certain to
get this to get these made so that
people could order them in time for
pride and like the there's available in
a crap-ton of colors but also available
in three different skin I'm sorry for
different skin tones so it you do not
need you know whitey make white ursins
fist there it is cheap plug check out
the mug oh wow I was high proof water
this is what I came for I want this love
that is inclusively made merchants yeah
I like I I have I have a friend actually
a couple friends who like it who are
part of the lgbtq+ community and they
get annoyed that like so much of the the
representation and the image or you know
even like stuff like this is built for
you know with one racial image of what
lgbtq+ is so you know I thought of them
and I'm like there's probably other
people too so like let's let's give it a
nice spread going
so quickly this game of thrones hold up
re-watch knowing the ending I don't know
I won't know until I try and rewatch it
I don't know how anyone could know that
cuz no one would have had the time to
attempt that yet alright so I think I am
gonna I am gonna wrap it up thanks for
tuning in guys that I think I think it
was a little bit weird this one it's
it's been a it's been an exhausting day
and actually once I get off this I have
to get on the phone and yell at an
insurance company who's making my life
difficult right now and I need a shower
and I need tomorrow to be a better day
to be completely honest so I think in
some ways I was a little off tonight but
this helped and this was nice and
talking to you folks it helps some days
it really does so thanks so much for
tuning in have a good rest of the night
go get some sleep
you're beautiful you're valid you are
loved and until next time this live
stream